quelle est la personne que tu as dans
tes contacts la plus connue à la plus
connue Rosalie
[Musique]
est-ce que vous pensez que vous avez été
le meilleur présentateur de ces arts de
ce dinards d'années non je pense pas ça
parce qu'il y a eu vous voulez que je
vous dise qui
a Alain Chabat Gad Elmaleh tout ça mais
il y a ça déjà et il y a aussi Florence
Foresti la première fois qu'elle l'a
présenté Xavier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quand tu paies ta tournée au salon de
l'agriculture
coucou tout le monde j'espère que vous
allez bien
je vous fais un petit message qui
s'adresse aux futurs maman qui vont
bientôt accoucher de leur premier enfant
voilà pour tout vous dire je travaille
sur un documentaire
et on recherche une future maman qui va
accoucher là dans les prochains jours ou
les prochaines semaines en
Île-de-France voilà